uh
white house pushes back as memorial day
weekend gas prices top three dollars for
the first time in seven years by the way
as of right now regular national gas
prices for regular gas
is three dollars and four cents premium
is 364.
diesel is 317. okay that's gas prices as
of right now
yesterday i was asking a bunch of people
what gas prices are where they're at and
they were sending me pictures
calabasas for premium was 489. by the
way if you're listening to this
can you post in the comment section how
much gas prices are
where you're at for what kind of gas and
what city you're in i'm just curious so
let's go into that story page six
uh story of gas prices okay so the white
house
on friday moved to uh quell concerns of
gasoline price on memorial day weekend
surging about three dollars per gallon
for the first time in seven years
regular gasoline average three or four
prices which are the highest for
memorial day since 2014 were 1.08 more
expensive than a year ago
when demand was depressed due to cover
19 demand destruction coupled with the
price war between russia and saudi
arabia in april 2020 resulted in a crude
oil prices temporarily crushing below
zero
dragging castle gasoline prices but
demand has recently climbed to a
16-month high
as more americans received the vaccine
and stated began states began to reopen
their economies
at the same time supply forward cover
has fallen to a 19-month low
of 23 days while prices have increased
from the low lows of last year as demand
drastically dipped prices at just about
three dollars a gallon are still
well in line with what they've been in
recent decades said
press sector secretary jen
said in a statement that p is silent so
let's just play a game here for a second
here there's going to be a
obviously a large contingency of people
they're going to say inflation
there it is it's the inflation biden
came in everything's inflated that's it
that's the end of the story
so just play a game and just be
open-minded for a second there is
something you don't need to have
a valuetainment economics degree to
understand the laws of supply and demand
right
so when kovitt hit supply was
very high and demand was very low
right you had saudi arabia and middle
eastern countries and
venezuela everyone pumping out gas and
all of a sudden there was zero demand
because we couldn't go anywhere
and now demand is back up people are
traveling it's memorial day holiday
you're you need gas you need gas in your
car you're ready to hit the road you're
about to have a good time
i'm going to minnesota for a family
reunion i got seven siblings i got well
that's a hell of a long drive from
california
you did you needed a lot of gas is my
point so it's a simple case of supply
and demand
now you do hear that inflation is real
and i'm not saying that it's not real
you hear the other argument saying that
it's transitory and it's transient it's
only here for a little while
and time will tell what's going on with
that but i do agree that this is a
supply and demand thing
and as jen saki says she says while
prices have increased from the lows last
year which is
obvious uh as demand drastically dipped
that was
basically march of 2020 price is just
about three dollars a gallon and still
well within what they've been in recent
decades which i agree now keep in mind i
haven't paid for gas in about 10 years
because i don't have a car but other
than that uh three bucks a gallon
doesn't seem far-fetched
doesn't seem inflationary to me i'd like
to see him change a baby's diaper and
then fill up his car with gas
and just see what kind of mood he's
going to know whatever he's capable of
doing right
exactly what's going to happen first
though the baby would probably be doused
in gas for all we know
jesus hey i got to clean her off a
little okay i'll play along with your
supply and demand thing to a certain
degree and the colonial pipeline
shutdown has something to do with this
on the east coast and that affects
things but
nothing makes people more mad then
watching those numbers go
up and up and up and it costing 75 bucks
to fill up your
your your tesla owners they're laughing
no that's they're laughing
but you know this can't continue because
a people won't be able to afford it and
b
this really really ticks people off and
it always goes in these ebbs and flows
and it happens and there's these peaks
and then
then somehow it gets leveled off so
let's hope
in the next month this starts to get
leveled off or there's going to be some
real blowback
towards biden because we can't live like
this that's too expensive for gas
especially when you do the things that
biden's doing when you don't want to
have any mining here
in the united states when things that
could alleviate some of this that's so
common sense and then you go this other
route
and it's just too expensive so i'll give
them a week or two three bucks a gallon
too expensive
genuine question oh my god i live in
california three bucks would be a treat
no
so here's let me just give you a price
of what you said 323 regular new york
city subs
suburbs okay okay 283 regular minnesota
costco price in north carolina okay 263
san antonio 349 regular in uh washington
state
uh 375 in jersey okay
340 in boca raton 349 in vegas
up from 229 since biden took off what's
gas here
410 regular 290
410 regular gas in la california 329
chicago suburbs
403 premium in san diego so these are
some different prices
435 for premium in bakersfield says
chris
joloff okay so pat is any of this
excessive
maybe i'm just being naive no two three
bucks doesn't seem aggressive here's
what i mean that's what you're supposed
to say meaning the the
the audi the party is gonna say it
doesn't seem that excessive it's about
the numbers
that's exactly what jen said jen said
i'm just saying for me this well you're
repeating what she said i'm saying for
me this i stand alone i'm not a party
person here
but yours is ability saying you're to
three bucks but this is
what she just said i'm asking
what she said i'm saying i don't agree
with supply and demand
you're repeating her words okay let me
read her words while prices have
increased in the low last year as the
man drastically dipped
prices at just about three dollars per
gallon are still well in line
with what they've been in the recent is
that true or not uh
i don't i don't disagree with that but
it's gone up and people are feeling it
look i think that's the biggest thing
that people are upset about
there are sir like i had a conversation
with one of my guys and he calls me this
was like six years ago says pat
i just had a meeting with my guys i
chewed them out because of you know a
terrible month they had last month and i
told them this and i told them straight
away
they got to get their act together i
said okay i said let me let me give you
some perspective on
chewing out when your
guys are not doing well and it's a bad
season
you lift them up when they're winning
and making more money than they've ever
made you have to teach them how to stay
humble
so the chewing out maybe you bring it
when they become too cocky to arrogant
during when they're winning
at the highest level right okay so today
all right today where we're at
what stephen druckenmiller said to usc's
business school he said i made more
money
in the last 12 months than ever before
he's worth 10 billion
dollars i don't know if we can play it
or not it's on twitter right is it on
twitter so we can play it if it's on
twitter put it up there we'll play this
on twitter
you have to hear what he has to say
you'll see where i'm going with this
because i don't disagree with you
but i'm going to tell you where i'm
going with this guy if you can pull that
up so
this is what you played for us in the in
the meeting yeah we only need to watch
the first minute so here's a guy
that's worth 10 billion that's telling
the world okay
just so you know when they printed all
this money
guess who made the most money you just
made the rich richer the more money you
printed
because the money constantly flows what
to the billionaires
so the billionaires know how to get the
money you just gave them more money
the money didn't flow to the people that
needed the money the money flowed up the
way you put it in the market because
no it's basically what you're saying is
when a man with experience man with
money meets a man with experience
a man with experience walks away with
the money and a man
the man with the money he works with
experience because what happens what's
that right what happens if you give
a poor man money what does he do with
the money he's going to spend that
spend it what happens if you give you a
rich man who is getting invested he's
going to invest it so yeah it's not the
fact that the poor are getting poorer
because they're not getting the money or
they're not getting handouts
they don't know what to do with the
money this is an educational issue
i want everybody to watch this and it's
going to get to your point that you're
making by the way this man you're
listening to stephen drunk and drunken
miller i believe
he's worth 10 billion dollars okay play
and see what he says
i'd like to know what he was worth
before the pandemic with the fed in the
inequality i don't think there has been
any
greater engine of inequality
than the federal reserve bank of the
united states
the last 11 years so hearing the
chairman talk about visiting home
shelters
homeless shelters is very very rich
indeed
i just had the best year i've had in 15
years last year
um everyone wealthy i know is making a
fortune
and why are we making it because this
guy is printing money like there's no
tomorrow
and the kids in harlem
in my opinion are not benefiting from
money printing
but stan druckenmiller and other wealthy
people are
so for the life of me i can't figure out
why the left is so excited about money
printing
um when all the data says
um the people that benefit from money
printing are rich people that know how
to
how to navigate what a perspective the
markets so so
okay so if you want to listen to the
rest of put the link below if people
want to watch it they can go watch it's
a two minute video i recommend you
watching it
here's what i would say to you adam i'm
not affected if the gas prices go to
twenty dollars a gallon personally
i'm not affected by it i'm 20 i'm not
going to be affected by it because to me
it's just going to be 20 times 20
gallons of my truck 400 bucks i'm fine
with it
i'm not affected by it so this isn't
every time they do these types of things
with gas prices it's like well that's
just the norm here's what's happening
the exact audience that they want to
help us who they hurt
help is the who they heard so now
inflation three bucks you're right it's
not nothing ridiculous we've had three
bucks in the last decade yes the highest
in the last seven years
the last time it was uh higher than
three dollars was under obama okay
that's when gas prices were higher under
obama's gas prices were higher trump
trump brought it down
biden's bringing it back up democrat
high republican low democrat bringing it
back up again with gas okay
why they sit there and they have good
intentions there's a lot of times in
life like the other day dylan dylan got
hurt he got injured
biking he's a pretty active guy so he's
got scars all over but he's like a
dash type of a guy you saw the scars
it's not looking good right it's pretty
bad you saw how to
shred it up so i i see it
and the first reaction when sennheiser
oh my gosh it looks bad to come like
so i come home and i said guys guys guys
i got this kid
i'm going to love on him but this is
something that he's got to realize if
you play sports you're going to have a
lot of injuries he has to know that this
is not the ending of it right
we went through it how much do you think
in that moment i want to love on the guy
kiss him hug him
i'm so sorry it's okay you have no idea
how much as a father you are in pain
seeing your kid be in pain
but that's not what he needs many
policies
we think are the right thing to do
because we feel so bad for people
look noble on the beginning but end up
hurting them
how many decades do we need to go with
the same exact policies until people
finally realize
these policies don't work you're not
going to bail people out of bad habits
rather than doing this teach them better
habits i'm going to make a prediction to
you here's my prediction to you
gas price is three bucks okay random
bold prediction don't be surprised if in
the next 12 12 months
gas prices go between five to ten
dollars a gallon let me say that one
more time
do not be surprised if in the next 12
months gas prices go to five to ten
dollars
in the next 12 to 24 months when that
happens
if gas prices go to 7.25 who takes a hit
wall street no who takes it hollywood
stars
no who takes a hit those who take ubers
you're gonna feel it
who takes a hit those who go and buy the
milk at the market for 3.99
now you're going to pay for 4.99 because
whoever's delivering that has to what
that cost has to be counted on for the
delivery of the equipment
who's going to feel it amazon price is
going to go up whole food price is going
to go up you know
kroger price is going to go up regular
day-to-day stuff you buy is going to go
up
inflation is coming there's no way they
can fight manipulating the market for
this long having interest rates being
loaned and one percent for a while
they are begging behind closers finding
the most manipulative ways to keep
inflation down
but it's at a point right now that you
can't do nothing about it 12 to 24
months when gas price remember
write this date down guy in your notes
so we know which podcast to go to to cut
the short clip
it's podcast episode number 65 and
today's dates is what june 1st
i want you to write down notes when i
ask you we're going to come to this gas
prices are going to go five to ten
dollars within the next 12 to 24 months
and you know who takes the biggest hit
low income low-income middle-income
family not wall street who well true
but that'll be one of the biggest crisis
this country has faced if gas prices go
up to oh
you'll see i mean there will be an
absolute river that's venezuela i mean
literally what's going on
but but but we're getting to a point
where again low income
middle income is going to pay the price
and
every time these folks keep keep giving
money out thinking it's the right thing
to do
you're hurting these guys my kids ask me
a question that can we get can we get
paid to
read a book no can we get paid because i
ate my food
no the other day the kids are getting
ice cream i come home like mama why is
the kids getting
oh because they ate good food let me get
this straight i said they got ice cream
because they ate their food yeah
since when do we give kids i said i'm
sorry dad my dad's sitting right there
i said dad did you give us ice cream
when we ate our food i said we got ice
cream once a month
i said i'm sorry babe how many times did
you get ice cream so we never got ice
cream
i said mama what is the system with kids
get ice cream because they ate their
food you're supposed to
so i brought the kids and i said what is
your ex i said so this is the ice cream
so oh
i can't stop them from getting the ice
cream it's in the freezer i said oh
really
so i now cannot buy ice cream because
the ice cream sits in the freezers and
kids can come and take it
so i grab the ice cream i bring it out i
said kids come here we're gonna have a
conversation together do you want to
trust yes
i said i'm gonna trash these ice creams
right now if you tell me
you are gonna go out there and take the
ice cream without asking permission i'm
trashing all of these
do you want to develop trust with me i
do daddy malva if you
cannot lead these guys without eating
guys just because they ate their food
i'm going to try to use
so what do you guys want to do no no no
moving forward no problem
you don't get ice cream for eating your
food america right now with the policies
we're just giving ice cream
to kids because they ate their food
you're supposed to eat your thank god
you have food to eat
we're giving people rather than saying
let's go create jobs let's go get a job
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye